j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
il porte sur ce chiffre
2950 milliards d'euros de dettes
publiques fin 2022 ça représente plus de
111% vous le voyez du produit intérieur
brut c'est le montant de la dette
française est soutenable pour notre pays
la réforme des retraites on y est encore
était indispensable pour rassurer nos
créanciers nos partenaires européens
vendant des battre on se demande comment
on en est arrivé à un tel montant avec
Jérôme Rabier elle court elle court la
dette française est de plus en plus vite
depuis l'an 2000 elle a été multipliée
par 3,5 frôlant l'an dernier les 3000
milliards d'euros et pourtant tous les
gouvernements ou presque promettent de
la réduire de la combattre pour ne pas
faire peser ce supposer fardeau sur les
générations futures comme Bruno Le Maire
au moment de présenter le budget 2023
alors je veux dire à tous ceux qui nous
proposeront des dépenses supplémentaires
en dizaines de millions en centaines de
millions voir en mill
sérieux lucidité mais aussi gravité le
remboursement de cette dette coûtera 60
milliards d'euros en 2023 là encore un
record
et pour en débattre j'accueille
Anne-Sophie elsive bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes chef économie du cabinet
d'audit BDO France Benjamin Lemoine
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes sociologue
chercheur aussi NRS et à l'École Normale
Sup auteur de ces deux livres la
démocratie disciplinée par la dette et
puis l'ordre de la dette les infortunes
de l'État et la prospérité du marché les
deux sont publiés aux éditions de la
découverte et Jean-Marc Daniel je vous
accueille aussi bienvenue bonsoir vous
êtes économiste professeur émérite à le
SCP Business School et auteur de ce
livre il était une fois l'argent magique
on est aux éditions du Cherche-Midi
évidemment Mathilde Siro est resté à mes
côtés Anne Sofia je vous demande de
faire un peu de pédagogie pour démarrer
c'est quoi la dette alors la dette on
connaît tous c'est pour l'État mais
aussi les particuliers les entreprises
c'est qu'en fait vous avez des dépenses
qui sont supérieures à vos recettes je
te souhaite vous allez avoir un déficit
et comme chaque année vous allez avoir
plus de dépenses que de recettes ce
déficit va se cumuler donc vous allez
avoir un stock qu'on va appeler la dette
et donc pour la financer vous allez
emprunter pour l'État sur les marchés
financiers pour avoir des des
créanciers qui vous prêtent de l'argent
et pour pouvoir et bien
rembourser par remboursé mais en tout
cas pouvoir faire que vos dépenses qui
sont supérieures à vos recettes et bien
puissent plus être heureux
contractés par l'État ce Benjamin ce
montant la vertigineuse de 3000
milliards de dettes alors évidemment on
voit ce chiffre on essaie d'aligner zéro
on a du mal à en prendre la mesure
est-ce qu'on peut comparer la dette d'un
état je pose vraiment des questions de
base mais je pense qu'elles sont
importantes la dette d'un État à celle
d'un ménage non absolument pas et là je
pense qu'on sera tous d'accord parce que
tout simplement l'État a une spécificité
qui est celle de sa capacité à lever
l'impôt et qui quelque chose qui rassure
les investisseurs d'une façon générale
dans la plupart des États la dette
souveraine par rapport à celle des
entreprises ou celle des ménages
considéré comme le placement le plus sûr
l'actif sans risque par excellence alors
évidemment entre état ça varie il y a
une hiérarchie entre des états plus
rassurants que d'autres mais en tout cas
à l'échelle d'un état le placement dans
la dette publique est considéré comme
l'actif le plus sécurisé par nature
puisque je suis dans la phase de pédago
la dette souveraine c'est la dette d'un
État ou la dette de la Banque centrale
européenne par exemple qui récupère qui
récupère les étages je me suis peut-être
un peu planté mais ça veut à peu près
dire ça le terme dette souverain c'est
généralement le terme qu'attribue les
marchés financiers pour qualifier cette
émission de titre par la puissance
souveraine et on insiste sur la notion
de souveraineté parce que précisément
elle peut avoir un impact pour les gens
qui prêtent parce que un souverain
pourrait par exemple changer sa loi et
estimer que les contrats émis dans sa
loi et bien sont annulés et donc il y a
une tension sur la des souveraine
puisque à la fois c'est un actif qui
rassure mais c'est en même temps un
actif qui peut faire peur puisque le
souverain il est aussi maître de la loi
comme j'ai dit mettre de puissance
régale et il pourrait changer les termes
du contrat qui le lit au prêteur bon on
a ouvert les livres d'économie on va
ouvrir un peu le livre d'histoire
maintenant Jean-Marc Daniel est-ce qu'il
y a eu d'autres périodes est-ce que la
France a connu d'autres périodes
d'endettement comparable alors à ce
niveau là non en fait quand on regarde
la situation actuelle d'abord d'être
souveraine c'est un anglicisme c'est en
français ça se dit d'être public c'est
parce que d'accord sur les marchés que
ça devient d'être souveraine mais
rassurez-vous c'est la même chose bon
c'est la dette d'accord donc les
spécialistes d'être souveraines
et donc il y a eu des périodes il y a eu
des périodes similaires ou alors non on
n'a jamais été autant endetté d'abord il
faut bien voir que en réalité l'enjeu
pour l'État c'est pas de rembourser
contrairement là aussi c'est au terme
main propre parce que l'État nous
rembourse pas l'État verse des intérêts
pourquoi parce qu'autrefois il est ces
engagements ces obligations étaient en
or il était obligé de payer en mort et
la quantité d'or était limitée donc il
essayait de limiter les sorties d'or
qu'il devait avoir effectuer donc la
façon qu'il avait trouvé c'est de dire
je vous rembourse pas mais je vous paie
des intérêts et je vous épais des
intérêts jusqu'à l'infini des temps et
donc on a plaisir
de quelqu'un qui est en tout cas roter
pour acheter sa maison comme ça
a été éternel la différence de ménage
dans un ménage une famille ça évolue ça
l'état il est là ok éternellement donc
on aura jamais on appelait ça des rendes
perpétuelles et si vous lisez Balzac
dont tout le monde parle le rentier
c'est quelqu'un qui détient la dette
publique et qui reçoit de ce fait tous
les ans une certaine somme de l'État
donc l'état limité les conséquences de
son endettement qui était lié au fait
que la limite qu'il avait c'est qu'il
fallait qu'il fournisse de l'or d'accord
pourquoi est-ce que on est plus dans
cette situation c'est parce que lors ne
sert plus de référence et donc on peut
s'endetter normalement à l'infini parce
qu'on fournit des euros et des euros on
peut en créer autant qu'on veut
américain il peut créer des dollars
autant que qu'il veut le deuxième
élément c'est que par rapport aux
périodes historiques précéd en général
c'était les périodes de guerre qui
considèrent qui arrivaient à faire de la
dette grosso modo le vainqueur sentirait
pas trop mal parce qu'il y a en sonné le
vaincu et donc le vaincu se retrouvait
avec un stock de dette et pendant un
certain temps le vaincu se refusait de
la force avant de préparer ça en
revanche pour essayer de là on est dans
une situation où tout le monde est
endetté sans être particulièrement en
situation de guerre et donc il y a une
sorte de permanence d'accord et le
dernier élément que je mettais sur le
c'est que comme on vient de le dire
c'est que l'État a considérablement
amélioré sa capacité à lever l'impôt
c'est à dire que les prélèvements
obligatoires auparavant été et surtout
il se heurte à des révoltes fiscales
régulières et là il y a de la créativité
fiscale
la soumission fiscale
est beaucoup moins radical et révolté
qu'il fallait être autrefois alors dans
un débat sur la dette il y a forcément
pas mal de chiffres je vous en propose
un autre la France a dû payer plus de 53
milliards d'euros pour rembourser donc
les intérêts de nos emprunts bah ça fait
plus d'un milliard par semaine là aussi
c'est quand même vertiginal Sophie aussi
à quel point elle a on va parler de la
hausse des taux d'intérêt à quel point
la hausse des taux d'intérêt ça peut
changer la donne alors c'est ce que
regarde en effet chaque État c'est
encore une fois plutôt de parler de donc
là vous parlez de beaucoup de milliards
mais c'est vrai que si vous parlez par
rapport à un particulier d'entreprise ça
vous paraît énorme c'est pour ça que
souvent on parle en pourcentage du PIB
c'est plus on peut plus comparer par
rapport aux États parce que voilà c'est
c'est pas comme un état une entreprise
donc en effet c'est un impact parce que
plus les taux vont augmenter plus que
l'État va devoir rembourser chaque année
va augmenter et donc ce qu'on appelle la
fameuse charge de la dette va augmenter
c'est vrai que pendant plus de 10 ans
depuis la crise de 2008 et bien on avait
des taux ultra bas donc ça permettait
aux États et bien de contenir cette
charge de la dette et certains pays
pourront dire peut-être d'être moins
efficient au niveau des finances
publiques en tout cas de profiter qui
est un faible taux pour davantage sans
d'été je vous rappelle que normalement
on a des critères à respecter dans la
zone euro grâce au panne stabilité de
croissance de 3% de déficit de 60%
d'endettement bon ça vous a pas
et donc c'est vrai que chaque État
regarde le niveau des taux pour voir si
ça charge la dette ne va pas exploser
c'est qu'il s'est passé pendant la crise
des dettes souveraines notamment avec la
Grèce et d'avoir et d'être en risque de
cessation paiement par exemple ce n'est
pas le cas donc c'est ça on va dire
entre guillemets la bonne nouvelle c'est
à dire que pendant 10 ans on est resté
dans une situation où les taux étaient
historiquement bas et même trop bas on
aurait dû normalement les remonter une
fois que la crise financière était
passée et on est resté dans cette eau
excessivement bas et forcément ça
rendait bien tous les étapes parce qu'il
est temps très endetté ça leur
permettait de contenir leur charge à la
dette donc aujourd'hui on augmente
certes beaucoup depuis deux trois ans
mais finalement on n'est pas revenu aux
situations qu'on pouvait connaître après
la crise financière et donc même si on a
une augmentation importante en termes de
timing finalement on reste avec des taux
qui sont relativement plus bas quand
vous regardez aux Etats-Unis on avait
été beaucoup plus élevé et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on regarde les tons les taux
justement à long terme et qu'il n'y a
pas de problème vraiment de
soutenabilité pour l'instant c'est à
dire de très très forte augmentation des
taux qui font qu'on pourrait avoir un
problème de remboursement alors là où ce
débat sur la dette est passionnant
Mathilde par c'est parce que c'est un
argument politique un argument utilisé
par Emmanuel Macron à un moment crucial
du débat sur la réforme des retraites
c'était le 16 mars Thomas dans l'une de
ces réunions à l'Élysée qui a précédé
l'activation du 49-3 pour la réforme des
retraites Emmanuel Macron a tenu cet
argumentaire devant ses ministres pour
justifier de passer la réforme sans vote
pour ne pas prendre en fait le risque
d'un vote négatif sur les retraites il a
dit parmi vous tous je ne suis pas celui
qui risque sa place ou son siège mais je
considère que les risques financiers
économiques sont trop grands des propos
qui visiblement naturellement en interne
on satisfait ce qui sont tenants de la
ligne budgétaire bien sûr Bruno Le Maire
Gabriel Attal à Bercy mais aussi le
secrétaire général de l'Elysée Alexis
colla puisqu'ils sont très attentifs à
ce que la note financ Ière de la France
ne soit pas dégradée mais autrement dit
si on prend le raisonnement du président
ça voudrait dire que sans cette réforme
des retraites la France courrait à sa
perte que finalement l'avenir du pays et
de sa soutenabilité financière
dépendrait de notre capacité à avoir
donc des dégâts supplémentaires et le
fait de travailler plus longtemps
évidemment ça a été du pain béni pour
les oppositions surtout après la période
du quoi qu'il en coûte et on a on écoute
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen qui s'en est
offusqué
le gouvernement Macron a fait 600
milliards d'euros de dettes en 5 ans
600 milliards d'euros de dettes pas 12
milliards dans dans 5 ans 600 milliards
d'euros de dettes ils viennent de
présenter un budget avec 160 milliards
d'euros de déficits ils viennent
aujourd'hui nous dire mais c'est un
drame absolu si on devrait forme pas les
retraites les 12 milliards de déficits
qui pourraient y avoir qui pourrait y
avoir
en 2030 nécessite qu'on mette le feu au
pays mais personne ne peut croire à ça
alors outre effectivement que cette
explication financière de la part du
chef de l'État n'avait jamais été
vraiment présenté tel quel en tout cas
pas officiellement donc elle n'est pas
vraiment pleinement assumée elle pose
aussi question à valider le procès de
ceux qui disent c'est vraiment un
discours qu'on a entendu depuis le début
que c'est une réforme qui est faite
pourquoi pour rassurer on peut
s'interroger Thomas quelle est la
souveraineté pour un pays qui se
retrouve à devoir déterminer ses choix
politiques pour une nation à en fait
prendre comme critères son niveau
d'endettement et le risque que que sa
dette dérive sur les marchés
effectivement au lieu on prend ce
souvent cet argument de dire qu'il faut
pas que la France devienne devienne la
Grèce qu'on en vienne à des politiques
d'austérité très drastiques la
comparaison elle avait été faite par le
président de la Cour des comptes si je
ne me trompe absolument et en tout cas
est-ce qu'il est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que dans ce dans ce
contexte actuel la politique de baisse
d'impôts d'Emmanuel Macron qui après
prévalu depuis 2017 aujourd'hui
elle semble de plus en plus remise en
question par des économistes notamment
et sans en passer par un retour aux
impôts ils pourraient y avoir dans les
dans les dans les semaines dans les mois
et la suite du quinquennat une pause en
tout cas dans la dans la baisse d'un pot
qui pourrait être acté merci Mathilde
cet argument du risque financier
Benjamin lemoins ce qui tient la route
c'est intéressant parce que en réalité
pas tout à fait la réforme des retraites
c'est par exemple les réformes
structurelles c'est des choses que
l'agence france-résor donc qui est
l'équipe au ministère des Finances qui
emprunte cet argent sur les marchés
financiers et qui est je dirais sur la
ligne de front vis-à-vis de ces marchés
et qui est à leur contact fait la
promotion des titres de la dette donc
qui est un peu qui sont les gardiens de
cette signature de la République et si
importante et donc ces références
structurelles elles sont présentées
régulièrement devant ses investisseurs
pour présenter un état de la France un
état économique mais aussi des promesses
futures sur les politiques qui vont être
conduites mais c'est beaucoup plus rare
quand un président va indexer sa
crédibilité politique à cette réforme
précise et on pourrait se dire que ça
pourrait presque se retourner contre lui
en quelque sorte parce que il expose
la qualité de la dette française comme
si tout reposait toute l'ensemble de la
signature reposée sur une seule réforme
et en quelque sorte il pourrait y avoir
un effet auto-réalisateur assez négatif
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on voit c'est que
les choses s'enlisent l'agence de
notation donc qui note les États qui
attribuent les bonnes ou mauvaises notes
aux États maudits c'est même inquiété du
fait que on mise tout un capital
politique on le concentre on le focalise
sur cette unique réforme en disant que
de passer par le 49-3 de passer plus ou
moins en force ça obérait les capacités
de réforme à venir et de
d'éventuellement poursuivre les réformes
qui seraient attendues par les
investisseurs immobiliers qu'il a pris
un risque avec cette petite vis-à-vis de
ces agences en utilisant cet argument
assez classique de dire c'est pas c'est
pas moi finalement je vous veux pas du
mal mais je suis obligé de le faire et
il y a le dieu marché qui à le faire en
mettant en focalisant son capital
politique là-dessus il s'est mis
lui-même dans une impasse et
potentiellement il peut mettre en péril
je veux dire paradoxalement la
crédibilité de la France en quelque
sorte en disant bah voilà j'ai échoué
donc finalement si j'ai chaud cette
qualité de signature française sera
peut-être remise en question donc il y a
une prise de risque un peu un peu
paradoxal et puis par ailleurs si on
réfléchit juste sur l'ordre de grandeur
non l'argument ne tient pas puisque ben
voilà ça a été dit le programme de
financement d'un état c'est 250
milliards l'économie permise par la
réforme des retraites c'est autour de 7
milliards il y a d'autres solutions qui
sont avancées dans le débat public
l'augmentation des cotisations enfin il
y a d'autres réformes possibles donc
bref c'est une erreur politique et puis
c'est peut-être même une erreur
financière effectivement qui sont nos
créanciers Jean-Marie Anne qui achète de
la dette française là c'est important
effectivement parce que quand vous
regardez qui détient le plus de dettes
publiques françaises en ce moment c'est
la banque centrale et donc des enjeux
effectivement pourquoi est-ce que c'est
la banque centrale parce que pour
assurer les marchés il faut que les
marchés s'ils ont le moindre doute
puisse se débarrasser se défaire de la
dette si ils se disent et donc il y a un
acheteur qui est à ce moment-là
intervient qui est la banque centrale au
moins de la crise grecque la concentrale
avait dit écoutez banque centrale pardon
européenne européenne même si en
pratique sur le plan comptable quand on
regarde c'est dans les comptes de la
Banque de France parce que justement
les autorités européennes disent c'est
pas bien que la banque centrale achète
de la dette donc c'est un peu un côté
caché cette dette que je ne saurais voir
donc on la met pas dans les camps de la
BCE on l'a bien dans les camps et donc
c'est la Banque centrale européenne qui
détient la part la plus importante
et donc et donc des enjeux qui est un
enjeu politique c'est aussi parce que
nous partageons la banque centrale avec
d'autres États la crédibilité que nous
avons vis-à-vis des autres États des
enjeux c'est pas uniquement de rassurer
les marchés financiers c'est aussi de
rassurer nos partenaires européens la
dernière réunion de
du comité de politique monétaire le
banquier central autrichien a fait une
déclaration absolument
ineffable contre nous en disant
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce pays qui veut
pas travailler est-ce qu'on va continuer
à payer la fainéantise des Français
effectivement symboliquement passer de
62 à 64 ans même si dans les détails on
regarde parce que ça signifie vis-à-vis
de la population autrichienne je prends
l'Autriche mais il y a beaucoup de pays
qui sont ce qu'on appelle les frigos
notamment dans dans les 27
et dans les frugaux vous avez des pays
assez divers parce que vous avez des
pays historiques comme les Pays-Bas puis
vous avez des nouveaux adhérents comme
la Slovaquie qui est extrêmement remonté
aussi contre nous alors le deuxième
objectif détient la tête ensuite vous
avez le deuxième grand bloc que c'est
nous nous détonnons une partie de la
dette au travers de l'assurance vie et
donc les banques achètent cette dette à
l'agence trésor dont on a parlé et
ensuite les banques en font des produits
financiers elles font un peu de cuisine
et avec ça elle nous donne de
l'espérance vie donc je reviens à la à
la question finalement posée par de
Mathilde c'est d'abord nos partenaires
européens qu'on cherche à rassurer avec
cette réforme d'après vous en ce moment
typiquement et avec un discours qui est
un discours qui consiste à dire certes
on va faire quelques économies parce que
dans la dette publique et la dette de
l'État mais il y a aussi la dette du
collectivité territoriale et la dette du
système de sécurité sociale elle est
portée d'ailleurs par une instance qui
s'appelle et donc c'est d'être là qui va
mais effectivement le les instances
européennes sont celles qui apportent
une forme de garantie ultime au marché
financier pour poser une question de
alors d'ultraber aussi ce que vous
disiez 7 milliards ou 13 milliards quel
que soit le chiffre par rapport aux 3000
milliards
le deuxième raisonnement c'est que si
les gens travaillent plus longtemps on
va produire plus et si on produit plus
on augmentera la capacité fiscale du
pays c'était si on travaille plus faut
voir plus long terme on va gagner plus
c'est un signal et le dernier élément
les derniers c'est un certain nombre de
fonds étranger qui détiennent la dette
publique française
en particulier le font souverain
norvégien et donc au travers de la dette
publique en fait c'est c'est ce que
disent un certain nombre de gens c'est
que la génération d'après elle va payer
la retraite des Français va payer les
les assurances vie des Français puis la
retraite est norvégien parce que les
intérêts dans les 55 milliards il y en a
une partie qui s'est réveillée alors
soupçonne pas forcément ça Anne-Sophie
elle suive ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que Macron il pourrait est-ce qu'il
pourrait renoncer à cette réforme sans
forcément provoquer une sorte de de
panique où on parle de la notation de la
de de la France ou de la lettre
française on est toujours pas mal noté
on est à ou euh alors je sais plus quels
sont les détails à grand ta petite a
enfin bon j'ai regardé ça cet après-midi
est-ce que cette note pourrait être
brutalement dégradée si la France
renonçait à cette réforme
moi je pense qu'il faut en effet faire
cette réforme et pas renoncer pourquoi
parce qu'on l'a dit c'est vraiment la
question de la crédibilité là encore il
faut faire attention sur les retraites
on parle toujours de 2027 13 milliards
c'est faux le grand problème ça va être
en effet de 2027 à peu près à 35 vous
allez vraiment avoir une très forte
baisse du nombre d'actifs par rapport au
nombre de retraités et donc chaque année
c'est pas 13 milliards one shot c'est
fini vous allez avoir une augmentation
du déficit qui va être exponentielle et
c'est vrai que pour un état il faut
quand même prévoir enfin c'est quand
même normalement son travail de dire bah
voilà on va avoir des déficits
croissants ce qui est assez intéressant
dans le débat c'est qu'en effet il y a
d'autres solutions on parle toujours en
France de ou créer de la dette ou
augmenter les taxes il y a aussi faire
l'immigration choisie c'est ce qui est
énormément de pays en fait comme
l'Allemagne le Canada les États-Unis ou
aussi avoir une réflexion sur comment on
peut créer plus de richesses pour ça
visiblement c'est vraiment complètement
à part mais il y a beaucoup de pays qui
le font et donc voilà dès que vous avez
de la croissance économique tout ça
s'envole surtout avec le tout ce qui est
vert comme l'a dit en effet sur les
partenaires ça je pense que c'est très
important parce qu'à mon sens c'est
vraiment ce qui explique par rapport à
notre crédibilité et par rapport à ces
frugaux là et qui explique aussi tout ce
qui est construction européenne c'est
que vous avez ces pays-là qui sont en
effet des pays qui ont plus géré leur
déficit public mais attention
historiquement c'était pays qui ont
profité de l'Union européenne pour ça
l'Allemagne à la réunification a pu
justement ré-augmenter en termes de pipe
parce qu'ils ont utilisé massivement les
fonds européens pour revenir à un niveau
Allemagne de l'Est par rapport à l'ouest
pareil la venue de tous les pays de
l'Est ça permet à beaucoup de pays
exportateurs de délocaliser une partie
de leur valeur de production qui avait
moins de valeur ajoutée pour justement
engrager engranger de la valeur ajoutée
en modérant les salaires donc il y a une
semaine en Allemagne il y avait une
grève générale là-dessus donc l'Europe a
vraiment été un gain très important pour
ces pays-là et notamment l'Europe du Sud
qui donne des débouchants en termes de
main d'oeuvre et aussi en termes de pays
un ces pays-là les premiers partenaires
commerciaux c'est les partenaires
européens et aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est que ces pays disent en effet la
France a fait quoi qu'il en coûte plutôt
que les autres et entre guillemets vous
verrez à crédit grâce à nous et on le
voit c'est très très fort en France et
notamment à Bercy et donc on est dans un
rapport de force en disant oh là là il
faut être très gentil avec les et
notamment les almas on les Allemands
parce que c'est grâce à eux un petit peu
qu'on vit qu'on qu'on peut faire qu'on
peut mettre en place et politique et on
le voit dans les Conseils européens on a
toujours beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
s'imposer par rapport aux Allemands la
vue sur les questions de l'énergie de la
défense parce que il y a cette question
mais j'insiste là-dessus parce que c'est
très important elle voit même au niveau
des médias et des journalistes on est
toujours avec regarder les Allemands
sont bien rigoureux légèrement il y a
pas de grève alors qu'il y en a une il y
a une semaine personne en a parlé dans
les transports aérien il y a rien alors
que nous standard fait plus de grève
Carrefour donc on est vraiment là-dedans
et ça c'est la la dette des idées reçues
j'adore ça dans dans cette émission on
l'a entendu dans le reportage
d'ouverture tout à l'heure 270 milliards
à emprunter en 2023 Benjamin Lemoine on
va trouver des créanciers facilement
enfin bon il y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir là-dessus non pas particulièrement
en fait mais je voudrais rebondir sur le
débat européen parce que quand même
l'éléphant dans la pièce quand on tourne
un peu autour de
ça a été évoqué par Jean-Marc Daniel et
il faut quand même se souvenir que le
quoiqu'il en coûte et puis après les
crises financières on est entré dans un
nouveau monde ça a été évoqué par vous
aussi c'est à dire le monde des taux
très bas voir négatifs ils étaient dus à
quoi ils étaient dus à cette action
massive des banques centrales qui
venaient garantir les dettes souveraines
alors comment elles agissaient en fait
elles rachetaient les dettes déjà émises
parce qu'il y a un marché de l'occasion
pour les dettes souveraine elles sont
d'abord achetées par des investisseurs
par des banquiers intermédiaires et puis
ensuite elles sont échangées en tracteur
financiers et bien la banque centrale un
acteur public institutionnel il venait
sur ce marché et ils rachetait
massivement qu'est-ce que ça faisait et
bien ça faisait baisser le cours de ces
obligations et ça se répercuter ensuite
quand l'État voulait émettre de la dette
et les taux d'intérêt baissés donc pour
le résumé très clairement ça arrangé
tout le monde et ça arrangé tout le
monde pendant 15 ans
biaisait totalement les marchés et qui
agissait au nom de la stabilité
financière puisque ce qui faisait peur à
la suite des crises financières c'était
la stabilité fin tous ces établissements
bancaires aussi ils se reposent sur le
filet de sécurité des banques centrales
donc le débat décisif et donc vous avez
raison de de parler du débat européen
puisque les critères de convergence
aussi sont aujourd'hui sont rebattus ce
serait de savoir à quelle condition
éventuellement ce cette sécurité de la
Banque centrale qui vient racheter qui
vient sécuriser qui vient rassurer tout
le monde à quelles conditions il est
activé ou non et jusqu'à présent il
était activé sans condition de façon
inconditionnelle on était sorti de en
gros de l'expérience grec qui était un
traumatisme pour tout le monde on va
faire différemment et donc les banques
centrales elle viendront racheter de
façon indifférencier toutes les dettes
souveraines mais le débat c'est est-ce
qu'on va le conditionner ou non à
certaines politiques à certains efforts
pour assurer certains partenaires au nom
donc il y a un vrai débat qu'il faudrait
avoir de manière démocratique pour fixer
ces critères là et est-ce qu'on peut pas
se prévaloir d'un monde aujourd'hui où
on prolonge celui-ci on dit il y a pas
de raison de de discriminer si fort
entre d'être souveraine le jugement des
marchés il est pas forcément le bon et
il est tout à fait légitime
[Musique]
le jeu pour la banque centrale qui est
encore une fois derrière c'est est-ce
qu'elle va dire à toutes ces banques
mais rassurez-vous moi quoi qu'il arrive
ça vaut 100 je vous le rachèterai ça il
y a aucun problème
le jeu est entre les mènes de la Réserve
fédérale comment entre les mains de la
Banque centrale européenne et bien
est-ce que en ce moment je reste sur ma
question avec ce climat on a eu voilà de
deux banques une banque on va dire
locale ou spécialisée mais quand même
une grande banque to big to fait c'est
le créditif tout le monde disait c'est
trop grand pour pouvoir faire faillite
bon en tout cas je l'ai entendu je dois
faire la boue mais
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a plus de
banques qui viennent je peux vraiment
des questions de bossières mais vers les
banques centrales pour dire est-ce que
vous nous garantissez oui il y en a
beaucoup en ce moment il y en a beaucoup
il faut faire la différence entre ce
qu'on appelle les banquiers de liquides
celles qui ont un problème de trésorerie
à un moment donné elles sont face à
effectivement des besoins des demandes
de leurs clients qui leur demandent des
billets qui leur demandent transfert de
fond et celles qui sont elles sont
levables c'est-à-dire celles qui n'ont
plus de toute façon structurellement
assez d'argent en caisse pour répondre à
leurs obligations le Crédit Suisse était
plutôt dans la situation d'insolvabilité
que dit le liquidité et ça fait un
moment que ça dure d'accord le Crédit
Suisse il y a c'est les circonstances
c'est à dire il devient le symbole d'une
crise qui le dépasse parce qu'il est le
symbole d'une crise qui est extérieur à
son propre destin et d'ailleurs les gens
disent bien il y a la SVB d'un côté tout
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis donc
silicone va les banques le Crédit Suisse
même s'il est et donc il y a pas de
menaces immédiate de Chris bancaire
comme on a pu le vivre en 2008 2009
alors sur la soutenabilité sur est-ce
que le le véritable enjeu dans tout ça
c'est effectivement la définition la
façon dont les banques centrales vont se
comporter et surtout l'utilisation qu'on
fait des fonds collectés c'est-à-dire
que vous avez des pays qui peuvent
s'endetter énormément parce que d'une
certaine façon l'argent qui est mis en
circulation par l'État à l'état il
dépense plus qu'on l'a dit il dépense
plus que ce qu'il ne retire sous forme
d'impôts donc ce qu'il dépense entre les
maîtres de sa population c'est nous qui
le recevons indirectement cette déficit
à 600 milliards de quoi qu'il en coûte
ça a permis de sauver des entreprises ça
a permis bon qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et
les salariés qui travaillent entre la
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait pour préparer
l'avenir est-ce qu'on en fait ce qu'on
utilise est-ce que et donc il y a des
pays où il peut y avoir beaucoup de
dettes publiques avec une utilisation
qui ne menace pas les comptes de globaux
du pays c'est le cas du Japon on met
tout le monde d'avoir le pays le plus
dans l'état est le plus endetté c'est le
Japon et ça ne pose aucun problème parce
que l'argent reste en circuit fermé
alors justement on va continuer de de
comparer la situation française avec
celle de nos voisins européens je
propose atteindre traduit de revenir sur
ce plateau
rebonsoir table c'était votre mission
difficile du du jour faire la
comparaison
oui effectivement et quand on se regarde
bien on se désole souvent mais quand on
se compare et bien là on se console pas
tellement
avec notre dette publique qui vous
l'avez dit depuis le début ce débat
avoisine les 3000 milliards d'euros
atteint plus de 111% du PIB nous sommes
bien au dessus de la moyenne de l'Union
européenne qui s'établit à 86% du PIB on
va regarder bon nos voisins tout proche
géographiquement la France et donc loin
de l'Allemagne et de ses 66 % du PIB
elle n'est pas non plus on va quand même
se consoler au niveau de l'Italie qui
fait partie des pays dans une situation
critique car la dette italienne
colossale qui inquiète d'ailleurs les
marchés avec ce risque que le pays soit
pris pour cible par les spéculateurs
entraîne la zone euro dans une crise des
dettes comparable à celle de 2010 2012
on n'est pas parmi les plus mauvais
élèves de l'Union européenne et oui les
plus mauvais élèves et bien l'Italie le
Portugal la Grèce et c'est près de 180%
du PIB de dette la Grèce dont la dette
publique décroît mais reste très
surveillés et qui tout de même depuis
2008 a connu pas moins de crises de
trois crises de la dette mais la France
elle est aussi loin du peloton de tête
les pays qui sont les premiers de la
classe la Bulgarie l'Estonie le Danemark
dont vous avez parlé dont les dettes
publiques plafonnes entre 15% et 30% du
PIB le Danemark par exemple un champion
dont les finances publiques sont sortis
indemne de la crise du covid on était
loin du quoi qu'il en coûte français qui
nous a protégé mais qu'il faudra donc un
jour payer alors quel est quel a été
l'impact du covid et de la guerre en
Ukraine sur les finances publiques de
l'Europe alors dans l'ensemble la dette
publique des États membres elle a Bondy
avec la crise du covid en 2020 et
jusqu'au début de l'année 2021 il y a eu
toutes ces mesures pour limiter les
conséquences sanitaires économiques
sociales de la pandémie elles ont été
très coûteuses pour les États et ça a
été parfaitement assumé par l'Union
européenne parfaitement assumée aussi
par la France avec et bien l'activité
partielle indemnisation des entreprises
l'assurance maladie le soutien aux
personnel soignants tout cela et bien ça
a eu un coup cela a creusé la dette et
puis ensuite et bien il y a eu de
nombreuses aides qui se sont poursuivies
pour protéger les ménages les
entreprises des conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine et maintenant de
l'inflation galopante et cela
un moment où le bloc européen s'est
affranchi temporairement de son corset
budgétaire le pacte de stabilité de
croissance qui limite les déficit à 3%
et la dette publique à 60% du PIB
puisqu'il y a donc eu une clause
dérogatoire qui a été activée la période
de grâce est terminée oui alors c'est
pas tout à fait le retour du pack de
stabilité de croissance que nous avons
connu mais oui début mars le commissaire
européen à l'économie par le gentoline
gentiloni pardon annoncé un retour du
corset pour 2024
la recommandation spécifique par pays au
niveau budgétaire pour 2024 qui seront
édictés en mai vous le savez
exigence quantitative ainsi qu'une
orientation qualitative sur les
investissements et sur les mesures
énergétiques conformément à nos
orientations en matière de réformes
recommandation seront formulées sur la
base des dépenses primaires net tout ça
n'est pas très très clair
il y a une partie de langage européen on
comprend une prudence parce
qu'effectivement et bien les critères de
convergence sont encore en cours de
discussion ça il l'avait précisé mais en
plus clair il prépare quand même les
esprits à un retour à moyen terme de la
règle des 3% de déficit avec une recette
en tout cas préconisée par Bruxelles sur
laquelle il a été très clair c'est
limiter et bien l'augmentation des
dépenses courantes mais ne pas couper
dans les investissements vers numérique
par exemple car il faut aussi préserver
la croissance c'est l'une des leçons
apprises des dernières crises
financières merci beaucoup pour tout ces
détails
je voudrais tiens parce qu'il y a
plusieurs thèmes à aborder qu'on parle
du quoi qu'il en coûte et je vous
propose de d'entendre une réaction
celle de celui qui est chargé des
comptes publics le ministre Gabriel
Attal réduire le niveau déficit public
objectif évidemment affiché par le
gouvernement on l'écoute ce budget est
aussi un budget de protection de nos
comptes publics nous sommes sortis du
quoi qu'il en coûte et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire déjà que nous étions
passés au combien ça coûte ça veut dire
quoi c'est là que nous avons un cadre 5%
de déficit à ne pas dépasser l'an
prochain je rappelle que nous avons
réduit le déficit public ces dernières
années il était près de 9% en 2020 6,4%
en 2021 il est de 5% cette année il sera
à nouveau de 5% l'an prochain nous
agissons avec un cadre
protéger nos finances publiques ça veut
dire que toute dépense doit être évaluée
un euro dépensé est un euro raisonné est
un euro évalué est un euro immédiatement
utile à la protection des français
Benjamin Lemoine est-ce vrai est-ce
qu'on est vraiment sorti du quoi qu'il
en coûte
de toute façon c'est la politique a un
rôle très important dans la définition
de ces périodisations mais c'est vrai
qu'elle peuvent être amusantes en
quelque sorte parce que pendant même le
quoiqu'il en coûte on avait déjà des
critiques qui venaient pour dire il faut
revenir à la normale la période qu'on
vit est anormale c'était de la même
chose pour les taux négatif on disait
c'est une anomalie complète une épargne
doit être rémunérée des taux d'intérêts
doivent rémunérer les épargnants etc
donc à chaque fois lorsqu'on vit une
période on a déjà des personnes qui
interprètent celles-ci comme étant une
anomalie devant CC etc et donc le covid
a été défini comme une parenthèse c'est
à dire qu'on considérait que pas
seulement en France au niveau européen
absolument et donc les moyens colossaux
qui ont été déployés je parlais des
banques centrales tout à l'heure mais de
refinancement de l'économie de rachat
des dettes centrale etc ce sont
installés dans le paysage c'est à dire
que ils ont été au début présentés comme
non conventionnel et puis le langage des
gouverneurs des banques centrales a
changé un peu celui de la France
notamment et puis on s'est mis à
intégrer ces outils là dans la palette
d'outils communs donc vous voyez il y a
un enjeu et puis on s'est mis à parler
en dizaines de milliards ça devient
compliqué quand un gouvernement annonce
un plan à 500 millions ça c'est quoi
c'est c'est plus rien enfin c'est on a
changé de paradigme politique très fort
à qualifier des instruments des manières
d'intervenir de pathologies d'anormaux
ou de routinier de basique et
typiquement lorsqu'on a évoqué la
Silicon Valley banque lorsqu'on regarde
un peu plus long terme les interventions
pour sauver le système financier par
exemple on voit qu'il y a un guichet
ouvert des banques centrales et que on
ne fait jamais d'histoire en quelque
sorte et on ne parle pas d'un quoi qu'il
en coûte pour la finance pourtant on
assiste de fait un droit de tirage en
permanence de sur les banques centrales
qui en fait injecte de l'argent public
dans ces marchés financiers les mettre
sous perfusion administrent concrètement
ces marchés financiers sans qu'on s'en
office sans qu'on dise il faut finir
avec le quoi qu'il en coûte pour la
finance par contre lorsqu'on a une
période d'intervention un peu plus
massive au service des états tout de
suite on a ces discours qui disent il
faut cesser avec cela il faut revenir à
la normale il faut revenir au
fondamentaux de marché les fantômes de
la rigueur et d'une discipline donc je
trouve qu'il y a une asymétrie très
forte entre un quoi qu'il en coûte
permanent à destination du capitalisme
financier et puis lorsqu'on parle de la
protection sociale des retraites de la
dépense publique on revient très vite à
discours il faut revenir à la normale du
bâton de la discipline alors je redonne
allez-y vous n'êtes pas d'accord donc je
suis pas d'accord
une sorte de liberté qui a été acquise
avec la disparition de l'or mais le quoi
qu'il en coûte financier n'existe pas
pour les banques il y a des banques qui
font faillite et derrière les banques
pourquoi est-ce qu'on protège les
banques parce que les principaux
créancier des banques c'est nous c'est
nos comptes courants c'est-à-dire si la
banque centrale intervient c'est pas
pour consolider et conforter le
capitalisme financier c'est pour éviter
que vous et moi qui sommes des déposants
on y laisse notre chemise et donc le
rôle de la Banque centrale effectivement
c'est avant tout de préserver les
l'épargnants et de même sur le quoi
qu'il en coûte est-ce que c'est fini on
a parlé du pack de stabilité de
croissance en réalité le texte doit
référence et le TSCG c'est ça c'est le
traité de stabilité sur la stabilisation
la coordination et la gouvernance qui
est le traité qui était voté en France
en 2012 qui définit que le déficit doit
être égal à zéro mais il peut y avoir un
déficit conjoncturel c'est à dire que
dans les périodes difficiles on laisse
filer le déficit parce qu'on dégage des
excédents dans les périodes favorables
alors les hommes politiques comprennent
bien la période où on fait du déficit la
période doit dégage les excédents c'est
c'est arrivé quand en France depuis 50
ans
il y a des pays qui ont dégagé et puis
il y a des périodes exceptionnelles qui
sont prévues par le traité comme l'a dit
le commissaire italien la période
exceptionnelle s'arrêtera au 1er janvier
2024 et donc
l'enjeu c'est que le quoiqu'il en coûte
quel que soit le nombre lui donne
juridiquement il s'arrête au 1er janvier
2024 à Mathilde
qui s'appelle il était une fois l'argent
magique est-ce que la France est dans
cette esprit de l'argent magique de la
politique du chèque etc quel est votre
regard là dessus ah oui oui ce que
j'explique bien c'est encore une fois la
disparition de l'or fait qu'on peut
créer autant de monnaies qu'on veut la
seule limite à ça c'est l'utilisation
qu'on en fait le problème de la France
c'est que on distribue des revenus sans
mettre de la production au regard là
aussi c'est qu'explique notre président
de la République dans ses vœux de
l'année dernière quand il avait dit
travail et
je me souviens plus quel était l'autre
mode c'était engagement ou et donc
travail c'est à dire que s'il n'y a pas
du travail en regard de ses moyens
dossiers qui sont distribués on va
augmenter les importations et à partir
de ce moment là effectivement le pays
est menacé parce que il dépend de la
production des autres pour son niveau de
vie pendant ces par rapport à ça on a
quand même été dans une situation
inédite depuis 2008 c'est à dire que
depuis 2008 les banques centrales ont
créé massivement de l'argent donc en
effet il y a plus l'or mais normalement
quand on crée toute cette masse
monétaire il y a de l'inflation et il y
en avait pas donc on crée on crée en
disant bah normalement en effet s'il y a
pas de collatéral donc en tout cas on
crée de la monnaie qui normalement
génère et s'appuie sur de la richesse
créée mais là en fait il y a rien on va
avoir de l'inflation on va être comme en
Argentine etc là rien du tout donc
forcément dans cette situation et même
on avait même des risques déflation s'en
souvient plus mais c'était ça le débat
est-ce qu'on va être l'année prochaine
en déflation chaque année on avait ce
débat donc ça absolument tout changer là
aussi dans la pratique des banques
centrales parce que beaucoup d'États
sont dit écoutez c'est vrai qu'on est en
plus tout le monde est surendetté parce
que si vous aussi bien comprendre dans
la dette on parle beaucoup de la France
ou de l'Europe mais c'est au niveau
mondial vous avez énormément de
liquidité en circulation vous avez
beaucoup d'agents financiers qui doivent
les placer et en fait il suffit d'être
un petit peu moins pire que votre voisin
pour attirer ses investissements et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on voit dans
les blocs ou dans tous les pays au monde
finalement il y a pas beaucoup de pays
où vous avez une certaine stabilité
politique ou votre président n'est pas
menacé tous les quatre matins dans
l'emprison ou vous avez toujours des
gens pour nous acheter et donc on est
moins pire sur le Global finalement on
arrive à nous prêter alors si tout le
monde est endetté pourquoi ne pas se
poser la question d'annuler la dette
c'est ce que proposait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon plus fort de la crise covid en
covid en plein quoi qu'il en coûte
nous ne pouvons pas payer d'autres n'ont
plus ne pourront pas payer il n'est pas
acceptable que l'on se mette en
banqueroute car ce serait le chaos il
n'est pas souhaitable que l'on se mette
en hyper inflation car cela serait
destructuré évidemment personne
n'envisage la guerre comme une solution
telle qu'elle a été appliquée dans le
passé il ne reste donc une possibilité à
faire solennellement et nous déplorons
que vous ayez refusé en commission notre
amendement proposant un rapport sur
cette question cette solution c'est
l'annulation de la dette ou du moins sa
conversion si le mot fait moins peur
d'une dette telle qu'elle est en dette
perpétuelle sans taux d'intérêt qui
viendrait sans ruiner le bilan de la
Banque centrale européenne à fondre à
mesure que l'inflation se ferait sentir
soit au rythme de 1% soit au rythme de
2% ou à celui que l'on voudrait
alors défi difficile nous reste deux
minutes donc annuler la dette c'est
possible alors non pourquoi parce que le
problème c'est que on peut le faire mais
il faut continuer on l'a dit comme on a
plus de dépenses qu'autre recette il va
falloir continuer à emprunter donc vous
pouvez en effet l'annuler mais après
est-ce que vous allez encore trouver des
créanciers qui vont vous dire bah
écoutez vous avez annulé la dette
l'autre élément on parle beaucoup de
l'inflation c'est un problème mais ce
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que justement
pour des pays très endettés avoir de
l'inflation c'est en fait finalement le
la première méthode pour se désendetter
vous avez encore stiglits de prix Nobel
qui disait bah écoutez on est à 4,5% de
l'inflation c'est finalement le meilleur
Odette le meilleur odepte contre la
dette donc l'inflation à 6% c'est
peut-être pas une si mauvaise nouvelle
annuler la dette oui donc non ce qui a
des croyances dans ce que dit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je suis contre la banqueroute
mais je suis pour l'annulation de bête
en français banqueroute ça veut dire
annuler la dette publique donc et je
veux faire des robes perpétuelles mais
comment rembourse pas puisque comme on
vous l'a dit on ne peut que les intérêts
donc la rend la dette elle est
fonctionnellement déjà perpétuelle donc
c'est complètement idiot ce qu'il y a ça
qui est inquiétant c'est-à-dire que la
représentation nationale qui vote le
budget ne comprend pas ce qu'elle vote
puisqu'il est incapable de comprendre ce
comment fonctionne l'endettement de
l'État je ne sais pas si vous allez
défendre Jean-Luc Mélenchon Benjamin
est-ce que l'idée est totalement
iconoclaste l'idée derrière c'est de
sortir de de cette musique de la dette
qui vient de Ré justifier des choix
politiques je pense que et on a des
solutions qui sont là voilà on a parlé
beaucoup de la Banque centrale
européenne mais on doit avoir un débat
sur au service de quoi cet argent est
créé par les banques centrales alors je
voudrais nuancer ce que disait
Jean-Marie Daniel certes elle protège
les épargnants mais là les protège des
excès du capitalisme financier elle
protège pas directement les épargnants
et donc on pourrait avoir un débat sur
qu'est-ce que le métier de banquier
aujourd'hui et peut-être que il pourrait
pas peut-être beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins de risques et beaucoup plus
ennuyeux et peut-être être moins
dépendant de ce sauvetage démonstral
mais peut-être que les banques centrales
pourraient être mises au service
d'investissement écologique massif et
rassurer définitivement sur les dettes
souveraines et ne plus
occuper coloniser l'agenda politique
merci à tous écoutez j'ai tout compris
j'espère que nos téléspectateurs aussi
merci de vous être mis à mon niveau
voilà qui n'était pas un spécialiste de
la dette et de l'endettement merci à
tous encore une fois je rappelle le
titre de vos livres Jean-Marc Daniel il
était une fois largement magique on est
donc au Cherche Midi
Benjamin Lemoine alors il y en a deux la
démocratie disciplinée par la dette et
puis lors de la dette des infortunes de
l'État et la prospérité du marché aux
éditions La Découverte voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission je vous dis à
mardi on travaille pas lundi c'est férié
et puis demain à 8h c'est Steve Jourdain
qui assure la présentation de la
matinale et il reçoit l'équipe du film
Les petites victoires c'est un très beau
film Mélanie aux frères réalisatrice et
puis l'acteur Lionel avait leur ski qui
seront sur ce plateau belle soirée à
toutes et à tous